wo ist dann als wellenbrecher und und
länder beschließen einen harten shutdown
rund um die feiertage und
einschränkungen bis mitte april von
lópez verzweiflung mediziner befürworten
den shutdown handel gastronomie und
tourismus sind enttäuscht leverkusen
zieht die reißleine trainer wosz muss
den bundesligisten nach zuletzt
schlechten leistungen verlassen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster bitten abend willkommen
bei den heute nachrichten an diesem
dienstag dem tag nachdem corona gipfel
zusammen mit norbert lehmann vom sport 1
im tor von mir ein größeres verwandten
treffen ein paar tage luftveränderung im
kurzurlaub wer so etwas vor hatte über
die feiertage muss darauf verzichten
beim berliner corona gipfel hat sich
gestern nacht die fraktion vorsicht
durchgesetzt und die notbremse gezogen
bis 18 april
so will man die infektionszahlen in
schach halten und dann ostern würde
sogar noch ruhiger als erwartet was das
heißt erklärt uns lud ihn ein muss über
ostern soll das land möglichst still
stehen die werktage gründonnerstag und
karsamstag werden erstmals zu ruhetagen
erklärt das bedeutet alle geschäfte
bleiben zu auch die bereits geöffnete
außengastronomie ausnahmen tankstellen
und unternehmen die auch sonst an sonn
und feiertagen arbeiten lebensmittel
leben dürfen am karsamstag aufmachen
alle anderen büros und betriebe sollen
fünf tage lang geschlossen bleiben
generell gilt im oster shutdown wenig
kontakte treffen dürfen sich maximal
zwei haushalte höchstens fünf personen
plus kinder oster messen am besten nur
virtuell
die kirchen sollen auf präsenz
gottesdienste verzichten
von touristischen reisen wird abgeraten
auch kontakt aber urlaub im eigenen
bundesland ist nicht erlaubt
möglich bleibt urlaub im ausland doch
müssen die fluggesellschaften nun alle
passagiere vor dem rückflug testen
auch bei nicht risikogebieten wie
mallorca bewohner von alten und
pflegeheimen können häufiger besucht
werden vorausgesetzt ihre zweite impfung
ist mindestens zwei wochen her und es
gibt im heim aktuell keinen corona
ausbruch das ergebnis des corona gipfels
der verschärfte krisenmodus stößt in der
medizin auf beifall
in der politik sieht das schon anders
aus nicht nur in der opposition
auch in den eigenen reihen melden sich
kritische stimmen
kanzlerin länder chefs und chefinnen
hatten gestern bis in die morgenstunden
miteinander gerungen
bernd benthin halb drei uhr nachts nach
über elf stunden verhandlungsmarathon
versuchte es markus söder mit einem
kalauer schuld sei nur die spd dabei
passt das lachen nicht zur lage
selten wurde so lange und so zäh
gerungen die kanzlerin zeichnet ein
düsteres bild
wir haben jetzt ja im grunde eine neue
pandemie die mutation großbritanniens
hat die mehrheit übernommen unter den
blicken unter den virus das heißt im
wesentlichen haben wir ein neues virus
deutlich tödlicher deutlich infektiöser
die kommenden fünf tage oster shutter
und standen so in keiner
beschlussvorlage erst nach einer
mehrstündigen sitzungsunterbrechung kam
der vorschlag auf den tisch
klar ist dass es richtig ist die
naheliegende zeit um ostern zu nutzen um
noch mal ein bisschen eine bremsung
hinzukriegen was das infektionsgeschehen
betrifft aus der opposition heute harte
kritik an den beschlüssen und am
gesamten krisen-management es ist zu
spät
es ist zu langsam es ist zu zögerlich
gehandelt worden
und das resultat haben wir jetzt ehrlich
gesagt mir fällt inzwischen schwer
irgendwas dazu zu sagen
immer mehr vom gleichen und glauben dass
ein anderes ergebnis rauskommt das hat
irgendwie nix mehr mit vernunft zu tun
und danach handelt die regierung auch
aus den reihen der unions fraktion kommt
mehr und mehr kritik der thüringer
abgeordnete albert wyler etwa schreibt
einen offenen brief an die kanzlerin und
fordert ein ende des schattens der
gestrige beschluss spricht leider erneut
eine klare sprache
planlos ratlos mutlos morgen stellt sich
die kanzlerin den fragen der
abgeordneten im parlament
das verlangt nach einer anordnung aus
berlin theo koll gut elf stunden
verhandlung und heraus kommt eine
notbremse ist die politik tatsächlich so
einfallslos wie es eben anklang
na ja das werden die experten im
innenministerium auf jeden fall anders
sehen denn die wurden von der idee eines
ruhetags am gründonnerstag ziemlich kalt
erwischt und müssen sich jetzt überlegen
wie man das überhaupt noch rechtzeitig
umsetzen kann denn eigentlich sind
feiertage ja ländersache und das müsste
jetzt noch von 16 landtagen
verabschiedet werden was einfach nicht
mehr zu schaffen sein wird aber was den
großen vorwurf der einfallslosigkeit
betrifft liegt die antwort natürlich im
politischen auge des betrachters wie wir
es gerade gesehen haben insgesamt
scheint mir die müdigkeit und
gereiztheit hierzu zu nehmen das macht
sicher auch ungnädiger in der
beurteilung der ganzen pandemie politik
der frühling war doch gedacht als
hoffnung auf freiheit und nicht auf eine
weitere notbremse und wahrzunehmen dass
wir nicht die effizienz weltmeister sind
die wähler dachten zu sein auch das
könnte eine selbst enttäuschung sein die
sich in diesem vorwurf der
einfallslosigkeit spiegelt den
schmerzlichen erkenntnis vielen dank
theo koll teilweise heftig fallen die
reaktionen auf die beschlüsse der nacht
in den betroffenen branchen aus ein
zusätzlicher ruhetag kostet die
industrie milliarden so der verdammt
verband gesamtmetall und die kirchen
deuten an dass sie auf gottesdienste an
ostern nicht verzichten wollen es sei
das wichtigste fest auch handel und
tourismus zeigen sich enttäuscht
peter böhme hat sich umgehört den
rasenmäher anschmeißen
was gibt es sonst zu tun das
ostergeschäft kann mag als haut aus
einem campingplatz am schweriner see
abschreiben
kempten im eigenen bundesland bleibt
verboten dafür dienen dass
fingerspitzengefühl
man müsste viel individueller gucken was
ist denn wo gibt s denn infektions
chancen und wo gibt es denn
minute urlaub formen und das ist camping
ist das nun mal ein film torlauf form wo
leute nicht toll in kontakt miteinander
treten
ganz im süden steht für christian bär
stinksauer am tresen
wenn es wenigstens den zipfel einer
perspektive gegeben hätte
doch er wurde wieder enttäuscht manche
seiner 150 mitarbeiter gehen jetzt schon
von der fahne
lieber fließband als kurzarbeit seien
alpenhof in murnau außen bilderbuch in
den trist es zur untätigkeit gezwungen
trotz hygiene konzepten wir sind
entsetzt von diesen mutlosen handeln der
politik den lockdown jetzt wieder
konzeptlos zu verlängern und es bringt
uns an den rand unserer existenz wir
stehen aber jetzt schon am abgrund
existenzsorgen die der
lebensmittelhandel bisher nicht kennt
doch dass nun der gründonnerstag nächste
woche zum landesweiten ruhetag werden
soll hält der handelsverband für falsch
gehalten das sehr kontraproduktiv was
die infektionsketten und das
infektionsgeschehen ange triftigen
gründonnerstag zu schließen und damit
den ganzen oster einkauf auf mittwoch
und samstag zu konzentrieren
dann sind so viele leute unterwegs das
ist nicht gerade sinnvoll sinn und
besinnung in den kirchen könnte ostern
einsam werden die messen sollen nur
online stattfinden
es ist eigentlich eine katastrophe weil
das ersehnen des gottesdienstes
riesengroß ist und alle haben sich
darauf gefreut dass wenigstens ein
bisschen positives gefeiert wird und
doch ostern ist das fest der hoffnung
für viele auf ein ende der pandemie die
krone entscheidungen der regierung
wirken sich unmittelbar auf die
lebenswirklichkeit aller menschen aus
und so hat auch jeder seine meinung zu
den beschlossenen maßnahmen reaktionen
zwischen frustration und verständnis es
war zu erwarten
es ist wie weihnachten plötzlich ist es
da nicht mitgerechnet
es ist konsequent für müssen wir leider
durch die kinder furchtbar für die
wirtschaft furchtbar also vor allem
verstehe ich halt nicht diese mallorca
regelung da darf man hin in deutschland
darf man sich nicht bewegen niemanden
treffen ich verstehe nicht warum man im
flugzeug beispielsweise nebeneinander
sitzen kann aber beispielsweise im
theater nicht es kommt da nicht mehr mit
und die beschlüsse habe ich versucht
worden
ich kann es nicht mehr
ich hoffe jedenfalls dass nach ostern
und die 14 tage danach eine besserung
eintritt so dass wir eine gewisse
normalität mal wieder recht und das sind
diese zahlen die den hintergrund für
alle diskussionen liefern
das robert koch institut registrierte
7485 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
gut 2000 mehr als vergangenen dienstag
250 menschen starben in verbindung mit
coupies 19
die bundesweite incidents steigt auf 108
was.de corona beschlüsse bedeuten und
wie es jetzt weitergeht dazu senden wir
ein spezial direkt hier im anschluss
außerdem haben wir in unserer zdf heute
app alle getroffenen beschlüsse noch mal
im detail aufgelistet israel wählt mal
wieder benjamin netanyahu ist zwar
regierungschef doch das parlament ist
zersplittert
die folge vier wahlen in zwei jahren
april 2009 10 ein patt alle koalitions
verhandlungen scheitern
es gibt neuwahlen september 2009 10
ähnliches ergebnis keine regierung
wieder neuwahlen
märz 2020 nach langem gezerre bildende
tanja und sein rivale ganz eine
regierung die schnell wieder zerbricht
also wieder an die urne
diesmal ist es wohl auf eine abstimmung
über netanja als pandemie manager
michael b warum jede stimme zählt auch
die der korona infizierten in quarantäne
in einem drive in können auch sie ihr
votum abgeben
mobile wahl ohne auch auf den corona
stationen der krankenhäuser israel
bemüht sich das alle ihr wahlrecht
ausüben können und hofft dass nach vier
wahlen in zwei jahren endlich eine
stabile mehrheit zusammen kommt ich
hoffe die rechten bekommen eine mehrheit
der mandate und bilden eine gute
regierung unter netanjahu damit es
wieder vorwärts geht
als patriotische israelis können wir uns
nicht vorstellen dass in der führung
unseres landes ein angeklagter sitzt der
immer einen weg findet die
öffentlichkeit zu belügen
damit ist er gemeint ministerpräsident
netanjahu
trotz eines korruptionsprozesses will
der nicht zurücktreten und liegt doch in
den umfragen vorn
je stärker netanya desto schwieriger die
bildung einer koalition gegen ihn bleibt
nicht zu hause geht werden
ihr könnt ruhig an den strand gehen und
party machen aber zuallererst geht
wählen
der rapid sein herausforderer von der
zukunftspartei spricht von einer
schicksalswahl
am ende gibt es zwei optionen und zwar
nur diese zwei entweder eine starke
zukunfts partei oder eine regierung der
dunkelheit des rassismus und der
homophobie diese wahl polarisiert das
land um politische inhalte ging es kaum
bei dieser wahl meistens drehte es sich
um den umstrittenen ministerpräsidenten
und so wird dieser wahltag zur
abstimmung für oder gegen netanjahu
staatspräsident reblin warnte heute seit
der staatsgründung habe sich israel noch
nie in einer solchen politischen krise
befunden
hunderttausende rohingya aus myanmar
leben als flüchtlinge im nachbarland
bangladesch ein verheerender brand hat
nun zehntausende von ihnen obdachlos
gemacht
das feuer in einem der riesigen
flüchtlingslager zerstörte viele der
notdürftigen hütten und
versorgungseinrichtungen von mindestens
15 toten ist die rede
die brandursache ist unklar allein um
die schlimmste not zu lindern sind laut
vereinten nationen in millionenhöhe
hilfen notwendig wieder einmal
erschüttert eine bluttat die usa zehn
menschen kamen dabei im bundesstaat
colorado ums leben
offenbar hatte ein mann in einem
supermarkt plötzlich um sich geschossen
dabei tötete er auch einen auch den
ersten polizisten der am tatort eintraf
mit einem großaufgebot konnten in andere
sicherheitskräfte überwältigen bei dem
täter soll es sich um einen 21 jährigen
sein motiv ist noch völlig unklar erst
vor einer woche hatte ein mann in
atlanta acht menschen erschossen
ein system aus schweigen geheimhaltung
und mangelnder kontrolle so beschreibt
der kölner kardinal woelki die
vertuschung von missbrauchsfällen in
seinem erzbistum das vergangene woche
vorgestellte gutachten nennt 314
betroffene sexueller gewalt basierend
allein auf dem was in den akten steht
drei führende geistliche wurden bisher
von ihren ämtern entbunden zwei weitere
boten ihren rücktritt an wolkigen die
kündigte heute weitere maßnahmen an den
eigenen rücktritt schließt er allerdings
aus dort ferber berichtet es ist ein
betonte reuiger kardinal der davor die
presse geht von schweren fehlern der
kirche spricht woelki betroffenen sei
häufig nicht einmal zugehört worden
dem umgang mit tätern und dem schutz der
reputation der kirche wurde mehr
aufmerksamkeit geschenkt als den
betroffenen generell fehlte es an
mitgefühl generell fehlte es an empathie
mit ihnen auch er selbst habe nicht
immer alles menschenmögliche unternommen
einen rücktritt aber nennt woelki ab das
ist mir zu einfach und in meinen augen
ist es auch falsch denn die probleme
würden nach meinem weggang bleiben so
ein rücktritt wäre nur ein symbol des
höchstens für eine kurze zeit hält ich
werde moralische verantwortung sehr wohl
annehmen
das erzbistum kündigt eine neue
unabhängige aufarbeitung kommission an
außerdem sollen akten nun
manipulationssicher geführt werden
beschuldigte geistliche stärker
kontrolliert und die priesterausbildung
verbessert werden
das alles reiche aber nicht sagen
betroffene die maßnahmen sind sicherlich
gut und richtig aber die
verantwortungsübernahme durch den
kardinal
die fehlte er war die ganzen jahre in
dem system mit dabei und er sieht nicht
dass er jetzt nicht der aufklärer sein
kann der den aufarbeitungsprozess
begleitet der kardinal und seine
konsequenzen aus dem missbrauchs
gutachten
sie überzeugen längst nicht alle zum
schluss schauen wir noch einmal auf das
thema das uns schon in der ersten hälfte
der sendung beschäftigt hat corinna
diesmal aber als hinweis auf unsere
zdf-sendung wir und das virus um kurz
vor halb neun
moderiert von meinem kollegen christian
sievers in berlin
hallo christian was bereitet ihr gerade
vor guten abend peter wir wollen so ein
bisschen der stimmung in diesem land
nachspüren heute abend die wir alle
irgendwie spüren dieses scheinbar
endlose warten warten auf eine
flächendeckende test strategie warten
auf die impfung warten auf den sommer
warten dass das alles ein ende hat und
dazu wollen wir den menschen in
deutschland eine stimme geben und ein
gesicht die gesichter dieser pandemie
wenn man so will
wir haben menschen hier die sich
zurückkämpfen mussten zurück ins leben
die mit dem tod gerungen haben wir haben
menschen die immer noch ringen um ihre
gesundheit
wir haben menschen die anderen hoffnung
geben wollen in dieser pandemie und
wiederum andere die jegliche hoffnung
für sich und ihr geschäftsmodell
verloren haben und all diese menschen
und deren anliegen werden darum
weitergeben an die politik und die
politik damit konfrontieren wir und das
virus nachher hier im zdf live aus
berlin petra ja wir sind sehr gespannt
christian vielen dank dafür
und nun zum fußball unsere entlassung
des trainers von bayern leverkusen
arbeit in der liga auf platz sechs
abgerutscht zuvor das aus im dfb pokal
und der europa league heute nun das aus
für peter bosch nachfolger ist zunächst
bis saisonende hannes wolf bislang beim
dfb trainer der u18 nationalmannschaft
hannes wolf als cheftrainer bereits beim
vfb stuttgart beim hsv und in der ersten
belgischen liga tätig ist aber vorerst
vom dfb nur bis zum sommer freigestellt
das konstrukt das es gibt mit der
ausleihe für mich persönlich ein sehr
sehr gutes um frei um voller energie um
mit allem was geht jetzt hier rein zu
gehen also acht spieler hat derzeit um
zusammen mit dem erfahrenen co trainer
peter hermann
das erklärte ziel europa league zu
erreichen eine ganze saison ist ein
marathon bei uns ist jetzt ein bisschen
800 meter lauf peter bosch wurde der
nicht mehr zugetraut nach nur vier
siegen aus den letzten 17 pflichtspielen
die dfl verschärft zum ersten april ihre
hygiene konzept für bundesliga und
zweite liga ab einem incidents wert von
35 sind corona schnelltest für spieler
trainer und betreuer zu beginn jedes
trainings und reisetag verpflichtend
zusätzlich zu den regelmäßigen pcr test
außerdem können bis zu 14 tägige
quarantäne trainingslager angeordnet
werden übermorgen das erste
wm-qualifikationsspiel der dfb-elf gegen
island heute das erste training ohne
toni kroos der verletzungsbedingt nach
spanien zurück reisen wird schlechte
nachrichten ein trio fällt aus wegen
muskulären problemen müssen niklas süle
und robin goossens kürzer treten
schlimmer hat es toni kroos erwischt der
wegen leistenschmerzen zurück nach
spanien reist wieder mitwirken kann
dagegen josua kimmig sein kollege vom fc
bayern manuel neuer wünscht läuft zum
abschied einen titel
ich denke dass wir diese erfolgreiche
ehre auch mit dem schönen abschluss
können wollen wir wollen ihm denke ich
auch ein großes geschenk machen nur mit
drei überzeugenden auftritten können sie
sich rückenwind für die em holen motto
verlieren verboten
das war allein zu hause vor dem rechner
homeschooling ist ja nicht immer die
pure freude in norditalien hat die
zehnjährige vier meter ihren
schreibtisch auf den berg verlegt wo ihr
vater siegen hütet eine gute
mobilfunkverbindung macht's möglich und
für pausen unterhaltung ist auch gesorgt
bei mensch
und tier so würden sicher viele gerne
mit ihr tauschen
heute ist welttag der meteorologie was
es in diesem jahr damit auf sich hat das
sehen sie gleich beim wetter mit es den
termin
das war es von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren marietta slomka erwartet sie zum
heute journal um kurz vor zehn
hier übernimmt morgen barbara hellwig
und jetzt geht es gleich weiter mit dem
spezial einen entspannten abend
physisches ein student und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter heute ist welttag
der meteorologie und das motto sind die
ozeane und deren wirkung auf unser
wetter
denn die temperatur die wärmeenergie in
den ozean steigt immer weiter an vor
allem seit dem jahr 2000 hat sie
zugenommen
deutlich zugenommen muss man sagen das
hellblaue ist hier die schicht bis 700
meter tiefe von 700 meter bis 2000 meter
tiefe ist hier in dunkelblau dargestellt
was man gut erkennt ist in jeglichen
schichten bis in 2000 meter tiefe steigt
die temperatur weiter an der die wärme
energie nimmt weiter zu und das wirkt
selbstverständlich auf unser wetter
apropos wetter wir schauen auf die nacht
und da gibt es im nordosten viele wolken
nach südwesten ist es eher aufgelockert
teils neblig bei minus sechs bis plus
sechs grad und morgen gibt es vor allem
im süden viel sonnenschein nach norden
ist es stark bewölkt und die
temperaturen erreichen werte bis 16 grad
im südwesten 15 im westen und 8 grad in
schleswig-holstein trocken ist es auch
noch am donnerstag bei werten bis 16
grad aber ab freitag kommt neuer regen
von nordwesten her rein und damit
wünsche ich ihnen einen schönen abend